[Música]
bienvenidos a este programa especial de
medio ambiente en france 24 el 2020 ha
sido un año de muchos retos de muchos
cambios y de mucho aprendizaje una
pandemia que paralizó el mundo tal y
como lo conocemos nos ha forzado a
replantearnos algunas cosas y a cambiar
modos de vida que dábamos por sentado
también nos ha dado la oportunidad de
darnos cuenta de que convivimos con una
naturaleza que durante muchos años ha
sido relegada a un segundo plano sobre
todo en las ciudades pero que cuando se
le da la oportunidad vuelve a retomar su
lugar en el planeta durante los próximos
minutos haremos un repaso por algunos de
los datos del impacto ambiental que deja
esta pandemia y analizaremos si la
aparición de este virus es un llamado a
reflexionar sobre nuestra relación con
el mundo natural
el intervalo entre marzo y mayo de 2020
fue bautizado como antro pausa una
palabra que resulta de la combinación
del prefijo griego antropo que significa
humano y pausa así se ha referido un
grupo de científicos al período de
reducida actividad humana como
consecuencia de la pandemia de ccoo y 19
los confinamientos en el mundo parciales
o totales tuvieron un impacto inmediato
claro las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero que contribuyen al
calentamiento global se redujeron
considerablemente tras la caída
dramática en los desplazamientos y tras
el cierre de industrias y comercios
entre enero y octubre de 2020 las
emisiones globales se redujeron en un 55
% la mayor caída se dio en el transporte
terrestre que dejó de emitir más de 840
millones de toneladas de co2 es decir un
15 2% menos que en 2019 los vuelos
nacionales redujeron su co2 en un 33 y
medio por ciento pero esto sólo
representó un ahorro de 89,9 millones de
toneladas de dióxido de carbono sin
embargo ésta
fueron temporales a medida que las
restricciones se flexibilizaron y se
retomó la actividad industrial o
comercial
las emisiones se nivelaron o superaron a
las de 2019 de hecho la organización
meteorológica mundial en su último
informe sobre gases de efecto
invernadero publicado en noviembre
asegura que una reducción de las
emisiones de esta magnitud no hará que
disminuyan los niveles de co2 en la
atmósfera donde se acumulan año tras año
sino que más bien aumentarán pero a una
velocidad algo menor la reducción del
tráfico motorizado hizo que la bicicleta
viviera un renacimiento a raíz de la
pandemia y se convirtiera en la manera
perfecta de movilizarse respetando las
medidas de bioseguridad contra el
coronavirus varias ciudades del mundo
ampliaron su red de ciclorrutas
disponibles en francia el gobierno dio
incentivos económicos a los habitantes
para arreglar sus bicis todo esto hizo
que el uso y la compra de bicicletas se
hayan disparado desde el comienzo de la
pandemia la búsqueda en google de
direcciones para moverse en bicicleta a
nivel global aumentó en un 69% entre
febrero y junio
2020 en europa las ventas de bicis
eléctricas subieron un 23 por ciento
comparado con 2019 un cambio en la
movilidad que contribuye a un planeta de
humanos más sanos pero también con menos
emisiones ya que cada kilómetro
recorrido sobre estas dos ruedas evita
la emisión de 250 gramos de co2 y
disminuye la contaminación acústica en
contraste mientras que la contaminación
del aire se redujo durante un tiempo la
terrestre aumentó con toneladas de
desechos plásticos como guantes o
tapabocas desechables que se han
impuesto en el mundo entero como manera
de prevenir los contagios la lucha
contra este material dejó de ser
prioridad durante la pandemia y se
sufrió un retroceso en los avances
hechos hasta el momento en cuestión de
leyes contra las bolsas plásticas o
elementos de un solo uso
la teoría de que el virus surgió en un
mercado de animales vivos en la ciudad
china de wuhan llevó a países como china
y taiwán a regular o prohibir el
comercio y venta de especies salvajes
las restricciones sobre los ciudadanos
impuestas por los gobiernos hicieron que
hubiera una mayor presencia de animales
en ciudades ríos o mares más tranquilos
sin tanta actividad sin embargo la
ausencia humana también trajo consigo un
aumento de la caza y la pesca ilegal
desde botsuana hasta colombia la falta
de recursos económicos por una caída del
turismo y la falta de personal por los
confinamientos hicieron que hubiera
menos vigilancia en parques o zonas
protegidas
un 2020 de cambios para el planeta y sus
huéspedes algunos positivos algunos
negativos pero todos temporales los
expertos coinciden para que los
beneficios se mantengan a largo plazo
sin necesidad de nuevos confinamientos
globales los gobiernos deben
replantearse el modelo de reactivación
de sus economías tras la pandemia y la
manera en la que nos relacionamos con la
naturaleza
para analizar precisamente esta relación
con nuestro planeta me acompaña vía
skype ana maría hernández salgar ella es
relacionista internacional colombiana
con 22 años de experiencia en
negociaciones ambientales y que
actualmente se desempeña como presidenta
del ibex que es la plataforma
intergubernamental sobre biodiversidad y
servicios ecosistémicos bienvenida
france24 tenemos muchísimas gracias un
placer estar con ustedes esta tarde
anamaría el origen del virus aún no se
ha determinado de manera exacta pero lo
que sí está comprobado es que la
destrucción de hábitats está relacionada
a la aparición de nuevas enfermedades
que podrían aceptar a los seres humanos
explícanos esta relación bueno
básicamente nosotros tenemos una
relación de interdependencia total entre
los seres humanos y la naturaleza una
vez que nosotros transformamos el medio
ambiente que nos rodea la naturaleza que
nos rodea inmediatamente nos estamos
afectando también y estamos entrando en
un choque que nos afecta
otros a escala global nosotros tenemos 5
causas directas de pérdida de
biodiversidad que también aceleran los
procesos de irrupción de enfermedades
por ejemplo en este tipo como la
pandemia y estamos hablando
ahí lo están pasando ahora la
deforestación o la transformación de las
de la tierra y de del mar son las
principales causas también tenemos el
cambio climático la contaminación la
sobreexplotación de especies y la
introducción de especies exóticas
invasoras
todo esto en su conjunto hace que
definitivamente rompamos los ciclos
naturales y eso altera nuestra relación
con el medio ambiente y claro nuestra la
convivencia con los vectores que son
transmisores de las enfermedades
todos los gobiernos hablando de
reactivación económica están hablando de
soluciones basadas en la naturaleza qué
significa exactamente esto bueno las
soluciones basadas en la naturaleza
básicamente son acciones que buscan
tanto proteger cómo manejar
sosteniblemente y restaurar la
naturaleza los procesos naturales pero
al mismo tiempo acompañando el manejo
adaptativo y dando al ser humano las
necesidades vitales que requiere para su
bienestar entonces básicamente lo que
aquí estamos tratando o en lo que la
comunidad mundial está tratando de
mostrar es que la naturaleza en sí misma
tiene diferentes múltiples valores que
son importantísimos para que el ser
humano pueda sobrevivir como especie
pueda a su vez desarrollarse
cuando nosotros vemos reportes del foro
económico mundial reporte de la misma
ibex y de otras fuentes encontramos con
que los ecosistemas proveen millones
trillones anuales de dólares tres para
soportar procesos industriales por
ejemplo pero también es cierto que
se ha demostrado que más de la mitad del
hippie mundial está dependiendo de la
relación con la naturaleza y con sus
servicios entonces qué haríamos de las
industrias si no tuviéramos las materias
primas naturales que son las que lo
sustentan
si nosotros tratamos mal la naturaleza
acabamos con ella pues básicamente
acabemos con la sustancia con el
sustento de la economía si nosotros
tenemos ecosistemas saludables una
biodiversidad robusta uno los
ecosistemas que están prestando
adecuadamente sus servicios que son
funcionales entonces básicamente la
economía también funciona y para eso
necesitamos una economía que no
solamente en palabras sea sostenible
sino que de hecho invierta en
el buen estado de la naturaleza para
poder asimismo invertir en el futuro de
la sostenibilidad del desarrollo humano
y del capital humano
y el 2020 además de esta pandemia ha
sido un año con récord de deforestación
en brasil récord de huracanes de
temporada de huracanes en el atlántico
es esto una manera de que el planeta nos
está dando un llamado para que nos
replanteemos nuestra relación con el
mundo natural del que tanto dependemos
bueno indudablemente lo que se ha
demostrado acá es que nosotros vivimos
como como en una bolita de cristal donde
pensamos que los seres humanos no
tenemos nada que ver con la naturaleza y
por eso tenemos una relación
tan
inadecuada con ella la verdad es que
nosotros tenemos que volver a recuperar
nuestro sentirnos ser parte de la
naturaleza somos parte de la naturaleza
y así mismo aprender y repensar cómo es
que nosotros efectivamente queremos
no solamente tratar la naturaleza sino
ver cómo está nuestro futuro en la
medida que nosotros conservamos la
biodiversidad apostamos por un manejo
sostenible apostamos por un plan planeta
saludable también estamos apostando por
una mejor calidad de vida nuestra y para
nuestros hijos entonces eso es la
reflexión de esta unión que nos debe
traer esta problemática que hemos
sufrido
y bueno creo que el gran aprendizaje es
que la unión es en la fuerza y también
los mejores objetivos son los que son
alcanzados a través de acciones
concretas que se logran entre todos pues
con este mensaje muchísimas gracias
anamaría por haber estado con nosotros
en este programa especial de medio
ambiente y esperemos que realmente este
2021 que comienza la década de la onu
para la restauración de ecosistemas
realmente si sea un nuevo comienzo de
acciones urgentes y contundentes para
sanar a este único hogar que tenemos que
es nuestro planeta sigan con más en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]